as small business owners catch a
collective breath from the pandemic top
of mind now is a potential recession
despite this and inflation many say they
are feeling confident and resilient we
find out why
cabbage and american express company now
out with its latest small business
recovery report after surveying more
than 500 small business owners across
the country in a wide variety of
industries chief marketing officer brett
sussman says 80 percent of them say they
could withstand a recession because of
what they learned during the pandemic
small business owners are confident
they're feeling resilient and what the
pandemic did is they forced them to
create a larger playbook than they had
before
and that playbook is bigger and better
sussman says the pandemic forced them to
reinvent their business go back to the
basics focusing on their brand and
incorporating new digital and social
media channels the small business
recovery report also revealed small
business owners raised their prices on
average 21 percent over the past year
and a half one in five say they are
going to have to raise prices again as
the year goes on inflation is a real
concern and it's coming from three areas
their suppliers are charging them more
the raw material costs are going up and
supply chains are snarled and they
expect that continue across the year his
tips for any small business owner
looking to survive a recession be
creative and innovative get online and
that really can expand you know who
you're offering your product to it may
move you from local to more regional or
nationwide
use digital and test into social media
platforms
he adds the following other tips
offering gift cards from your store
online to customers is a big boost and
if you're a small business owner who can
subdivide your space take in a second
tenant with a supplementary business to
reduce your rental and overhead costs